[Music]
whoa that's more scary hey bud I brought
here to show you a cartoon I would
rather if you didn't keep saying you
brought me here and like I came here on
my own
I had a car sent for you but you didn't
brought you're lying and because you're
in my cartoon studio where I like to
show older cartoons a lot of relevant
your lair to today's world okay today's
is called bimbos initiation it's by the
Fleischer brothers who did a vegetable
yeah well bimbos were guys who back then
they were like guys who'd beat people up
like Street for all our time in those
were Street brawlers yeah okay and what
is it called again those initiation buzz
initiation that's not good that right
away that's yeah that's good okay gang
initiation
well not that bad bimbeau the Freemasons
join a gang huh I'll drink blood good
right sure so the Fleischer brothers
they really had a handle on this
business yeah they did talk our tunes
yeah which we all remember this is long
the credit to not short so there's uh
there's that's a bimbo okay oh man that
happened Mickey Mouse locks in there
what yeah apparently Disney goes into
freedom and stuff yeah so this is a
pretty typical manhole at the time yeah
for sure
oh so he really is going to like a Mason
so these are the scary [ __ ] yeah well
there's a lots going on
BIRT want to be a member no nope he said
no okay so he goes back up to his boring
life Morpheus just offered him the red
or blue pill and so he's like I can
leave it just takes off oh oh it's a
trick why do Oh No if you don't want to
be a freemason and everything just goes
really crazy there at everything they're
like bedbug member want to be a member
now why would you not say oh these in
the Jamiroquai rooms gonna go inside of
it hey it's still behind you he's gotta
let me zoom illusion well that's not
very sexual level let it go in just the
tip give it a taste
oh thank god that's there guess what
you're gonna get asked if you wanted to
be a member
as you can see cool if you don't join
the Freemasons then there's a lot of
problem yeah it feels like they're kind
of dicks
Wow life seems I wait a minute Dave
sorry we got bigger fish to fry right
now fires even no oh right this is what
fires do it's gonna be bad just say
you'll join join I love it turn the Mesa
join them join the Mason kool-aid that's
not a good plan Oh
Hey they really switched the stakes or
he didn't ask if they won Hannover wanna
be a member now so this is pretty subtle
man you know what do I take well it's me
right
Who am I what's happening he drank
ayahuasca I think right yep
Oh get out of here oh boy spanking
machine no I had one of these but I've
had a more like a long
oh no yours is totally different and
it's technically hooked up to yard
equipment so what his ass is still on
fire from his spanking machine
you've been spanked like that no let me
try your ass is on fire for a while oh
yeah I've had bugs parachute from my ass
how do I think about it I have it this
and it's all the tricks man
oh that's Betty Boop thank God someone
we could trust Betty oh by the way she's
a dog but did you see her ears hold on
there's many some doors of thick doors
about another day what's frustrating
today oh there you go
time to get sucked in that was just a
time waster yeah someone's gonna have a
sore bottom tomorrow look join the Mesa
join I join yeah why not it's just a
club yeah this is hell I'm sure that has
meaning to Mason look oh my good boy
it's a shame we should stop ahead of
it's a shadow don't don't bring logic
into this whoa no this is definitely
ayahuasca and then there's our cats No
hello look she has dog ears oh oh
I think moves but he's a dog technically
right so wouldn't you want dog ears yeah
I think she's this is one of the first
cartoon she was in so she's a dog so
she's okay
the mention becomes a lady later on yes
is it and when you're amazing it's all
good so they're all ladies it's a big
[ __ ] party yeah so truly the moral is
become a Mason yeah be a Mason
she's so apparently Betty Boop later on
becomes human and then when the rating
system kicked in they're like oh we
can't have a dog [ __ ] a lady so then
they got rid of it they yeah
and bimbo wasn't in cartoons anymore
wait wait one more time Betty Boop was a
dog that becomes a lady and this is like
early Betty Boop she's a dog ratings
okay so she had the ears and then and
then at some point they're like well
it's a dog can't [ __ ] a lady and then so
they heard a static got rid of bimbo
instead of they should use me I'm human
but they got rid of him I I'm not on
snapchat what happens there's a lot of
animal filters I believe it'll lead to
bestiality eventually anyway so it's
because people like they were worried
that they were like promoting well no
because a rating system came in and once
the rating systems came in
was like I can't have dogs [ __ ] lady
cartoons and when we just drawn a line
we were just like live cartoons would do
them I mean thanks for bringing me here
I'm gonna get you back in the car
[Music]
you